so first because I love Ghost Stories
haunted houses and all that kind of
stuff did you have a ghost story that
haunted you as a kid growing up
something that maybe even every now and
then you think about today yeah there
was one time I remember uh some kids in
the neighborhood we had climbed on this
roof of like a house that like no one
lived there and I you know felt like
that I saw somebody in the window and
bolted and everyone saw me bolt and they
uh ran and then they were like why are
we running I go I think I saw something
in the window so I've never sure if I
actually did or if I just wanted to kind
of pump up the excitement on a summer
day those thoughts tickle me to no end I
love that stuff we had Sleepaway Camp
cropsy and I love thinking about cropsy
every once in a while and the orange
cropsy moon yeah what's that mean crop
Scene It is a like an evil entity that
used to haunt the Sleepaway Camp that I
went to and whenever the moon would turn
orange it would be a cropsy moon and
everyone would be on high alert yes yeah
I feel like there's an actual legit
cropsy documentary out there it's really
like the true stuff that happened to
cropsy Moon Yeah gotta watch out for
that I think about that too much
speaking of which you need to make more
horror movies yeah it's been a long time
well I guess what was I did
um yeah uh I did one other one like
anacondas it's a it's a Monster yeah
That's genre
um but it is kind of a genre that sort
of seems
um recession-proof it's like people
always kind of yeah they what is it
about us that wants to be scared uh I
didn't be scared in a safe space yeah I
think that's what it is very well said I
am putting in the order for you to do
another movie later please
um I wanted to highlight Justin's work
on this film because I'm really excited
about the idea of him getting to direct
a big Studio film and I've got high
hopes he'll wind up doing more in the
future if that's what he wants at least
so what is something about him as an
actor's director and a leader on a
project of this scale that you would be
excited for more actors out there to get
to experience well I mean it was kind of
you know for just I think this was like
a really you know it's a big Disney
movie and right from when I first talked
to him and we were kind of talking about
the character he just has a very kind of
uh engaging kind of upbeat way of
talking with everyone and actors and you
always felt kind of comfortable to kind
of try stuff and encourage and he could
kind of come up with good lines himself
and good ideas because he has a good
sense of humor
um and just kind of you know unflappable
and that's kind of a nice quality and a
director too especially for somebody
kind of coming on to something so
overwhelming and just always kind of
stayed himself speaking of the rest of
your team now they just released a
featurette today that highlighted uh the
importance of having a good Ensemble
here and also how much fun you all had
working together so can you give me an
example of a time on this set when like
a scene partner gave you just what you
needed and it made something in your own
performance even better yeah
um I actually think some of the ghosts
you know some of the makeup and
everything that the way these ghosts
look was you know pretty
um you know terrifying kind of and
unnerving and so that was just one less
thing to act uh because it is
um yeah it kind of throws you and so it
was easy to sort of get that feeling
that is a guy
right now given the fact that you have
worked on many you know big Studio
movies with a lot of VFX is there
anything that made like even you go
while you were standing on this set like
I cannot believe this is what it takes
to make it look like that on screen in
the end yeah I think just
um you know the sets and kind of
building kind of these you know mansions
and some of the sort of the outdoor
scenes that we did
um that were you know still shot on a
stage but then out on like the back lot
and it was you know sometimes you go to
work on a movie and it's kind of a you
know small movie and
um you know it's fun to work on but this
was kind of a movie where you're like
whoa this is a big Hollywood movie when
you saw those sets and uh how kind of
impressive they were and again sort of
like with the ghosts it's uh one less
thing to act you feel it while you're
watching even just trailers and
promotion material I'm already catching
myself like pausing on every single
frame to look for a little hidden
details so yeah is there anything while
you're on set that you caught in the
production design that just like caught
your eye and you appreciated and you
hope that viewers when they see the
movie will pay attention to that thing
well I think you know we also were in
New Orleans and shooting at some of
those places and the way these trees
looked it's funny that I'm kind of
talking about the trees but it was just
kind of this long road flanked by trees
and these trees were like you know uh
what was the name of that scary Moon
that you talked about cropsy Moon it's
like you would not want to have a cropsy
moon in these trees yeah I would I would
enjoy that a little bit of a silly
question for you so you as in real you
you have to spend a night in a haunted
house you could pick two Haunted Mansion
cast members to team up with who do you
choose that you think would give you the
best chance of surviving the night in
the haunted house
um I think Rosario you know kind of her
work sort of you know in uh you know
Mandalorian and uh she's very capable
and that's just kind of her kind of
upbeat
um Spirit uh so definitely her and then
um Jamie Lee Curtis uh she's pretty
formidable too as a person so I could
see both of them kind of calming me I
think that sounds like a perfect pairing
to me so now for your character in
particular going into this whole crazy
mystery can you give me at the beginning
of the film what you think his greatest
strength is but then also I want his
greatest weakness the thing that could
stop him from being a good team player
maybe and figuring out the mystery I
think uh my character's greatest
strength is his probably his enthusiasm
in getting people sort of to play as a
team and supporting everyone and then
his weakness is uh his sort of
relationship with the truth is
um you know not you know completely
faithful okay interesting peak in my
interest right now I've already had Sky
High Hopes for this movie that makes me
want to see it even more congratulations
thank you thank you